um so um uh if you could get the i mean
by the way you this question might not
pertain to you because i would imagine a
lot of people want to work with you but
if you could get the financing for any
project what would you make and why
huh
um
that's a great question
you know i i have i have a backlog of
ideas
things that i've been working on kind of
in the margins and from time to time and
really
it's not one thing you know i i've been
really lucky um in the sense that
i get to make these movies that are
about something you know that that that
have a message to them and so
i've been very fortunate there's nothing
that i've wanted to make that i haven't
ultimately been able to make you know um
i'm also really for whatever reason i
don't really know why i'm incredibly
picky and so when i when i fall in love
with something i i'm i fall all in and
so
so you know
yeah i'd say you know hopefully you know
my magic wand you're gonna get to see
over the next five to six years got it i
like okay um if you could go back in
time to the first day of filming dear
evan hansen
what do you what would you like to tell
yourself on the first day of filming
that you learned during the shoot
um
i you know it's funny i i don't know if
i could have
possibly given myself advice uh on that
first day because
just the effect of being isolated for as
long as we were all isolated you know
from each other but then from our
families i think i think maybe what i
would say is look it's all going to work
out it's all going to be okay you know
just just that fundamental thing because
it was scary day in day out not only was
it scary like you know to go to work
i always felt so responsible for
everybody and i was worried for
everyone's health and safety but i was
also so worried about my family back at
home um that i think that it's just like
if i could crystal ball it if i knew i'd
go back and say it's all gonna be okay
take a deep breath and just keep keep
moving forward
i can't imagine what it's like
for a director when you are directing
some big project like this that
everybody knows about and i would
imagine a lot of people want to be in it
so what is it like for you in terms of
when you're in that casting process how
many people are calling you being like i
know the right person for this role
well luckily i mean quite a few people
um were interested in and that's a
blessing you know if you have a piece of
material that is this strong you know
and the three authors are so so talented
that it it it is this strong that um
you know it
it's an embarrassment of riches and so
now what you're doing is what you're
casting is you're not you're not you're
really lucky you're able to to look for
not only the best person for each part
but you're able to look from
at it from
the standpoint of the ensemble you know
it's not just it's not just the one
person or the it's the one in one make
three you know there's there's each role
plus there's the chemistry between the
relationship is as important as the
character sometimes sometimes even more
so so no it's it's fantastic you know
the more interest the better cast you
get and and
i i love actors so much at the end of
the day it's all about them you know
performing this beautiful piece of
material so it was great
one of the things that i love about this
material is the way it shines a light on
uh mental health and uh can you sort of
talk about i feel like in the last few
years
the ability to talk about mental health
has actually been easier like people are
talking about it and the stigma is maybe
being a little bit reduced uh what are
your what's your take on this
um
yeah i feel that that every time you
talk about it it brings more light to it
you know whether it's it's mental health
or it's depression anxiety or suicide
whatever that whatever the subject is
and i've been really lucky and i i've
i've been very focused in my career to
talk about things that sometimes movies
don't talk about you know but but to do
it not as like not preaching but just to
talk about it almost
it's sometimes just matter-of-factly or
emotionally where you're not trying to
be this message person or whatever
you're just trying to tell the story um
but to me the more these things are
talked about the more the more they
become normal and so often it's the
stigma that's the problem it's not the
thing itself the thing itself if you
just deal with it it can be dealt with
just like anything else if you broke
your arm you know you you would go to
the doctor you'd get a cast right but if
the thing that's broken is internal or
it's mental or it's invisible you know
to the naked eye that's a little harder
so so so often and we all know this we
all have these friends where you you you
know sometimes people what the worst
thing that you have to deal with is just
someone saying look it's come on it's
all in your head snap out of it but like
but i can't it's impossible to snap out
of so now what right so so i think that
dear evan hansen um
is part of the solution here it's part
of just talking about things that that
uh and
that so many of us face and if we don't
face them then somebody in our family or
a friend is you know so so uh yeah i'm
very proud i'm proud that we were able
to talk about this stuff oh i'm super
happy you made this film and how good it
is um uh things on the stage are a
two-act structure a movie is a three-act
structure
can you sort of talk about uh moving it
from the stage to this to the screen and
figuring out the three-act structure
yeah well that was something i was i was
quite happy about because you know i
knew that i had this incredible
screenwriter in steven levinson and he
did a lot of tv work he's done you know
uh certainly a lot of stage work um but
you know he was fairly new to the movie
game um he's fairly new to movies uh at
the time so it's really exciting because
he's so intuitively brilliant
so it was really two things that i i
said right away i said
uh
you know hey guys like the intermission
is so great in your show but we can't
really do an intermission so would it be
okay to like just i would love to just
see them take off that cast i think it'd
be really great to kind of like hit a
reset button in the story because
you know the cast then represents the
intermission so it makes it a little
more seamless and they were all in and
it was really fun and i love justin and
dan rummer wrote a wonderful piece of
music to accompany it so i it was a
really great moment um i was excited
about that but the other one was in
terms of the third act and how to make a
third act work was
was you know i always felt that he
should confess
you know i always felt that it was
lovely that conor's family did not out
him and did not expose him to the
community but then i thought well is he
can still lie that he was friends with
connor at his tenth high school reunion
things like these these questions kept
plaguing me so i threw out to the guys
like hey um would you be willing to have
him go on a quest and maybe just come
clean because if if the
the theme of your show is
you know be yourself or it's like no
hiding no lying you know uh right now
you're you and that's enough then
shouldn't he be able to come clean to
the community and they were all in but
the way they executed it i thought was
perfect you know it involved that new
song a little closer which was lovely
and and the reveal of conor um which
obviously you can't talk about but
anyway
you know it's it's one of those things
where i just thought that the search for
connor
you know coming up with this idea and
knowing a little bit more about him and
then um evan coming clean really
provided a nice third act
well i do want to specifically without
doing any spoilers on the third act i
love the ending of this movie um what
were you
i guess what was
it's
so many people are so
um invested in this material how i mean
and the third act is all new were you
sort of using the new ending like did
you test it on anyone in terms of is
this gonna work for the fans are we sort
of like it works for me and that's and i
know this is enough
no i we certainly previewed it because
you know the the
the opinion of the fans meant a lot to
me i'm one of those fans you know i i
love the show that's why i wanted to
make the movie i didn't i didn't make i
didn't make the movie because i thought
the show was broken i thought the show
was brilliant and i just i i just
thought i saw some opportunities you
know to to get a little more intimate
with the close-ups and using this you
know that kind of thing but the third
act was again um
we did preview it and and the audience
seemed to respond really well you know
the fans of the show seem to love
it it's like they got to see more you
know things that that may be um you know
there's two new songs that's exciting
you know they can always people could
almost go back to the stage show that
and and i want them to i think the stage
show is amazing but no people seem to be
very very open to what we did and and
they knew the reason why we did it and
so yeah it's been very very um positive
you know because also going back to
maybe the spirit of your question is i'm
not the i'm not the kind of director
that's like you know pleasing me is that
you know i i don't i don't it's it's i
just find that
you know you make movies i like to make
movies because i could write novels i
make movies because i love the
collaboration i love people's uh
opinions i love
um that sense of camaraderie it makes it
fun i love i love the the collective
experience and have all these amazing
artists around me um you know these
authors who are so brilliant that it's
like why wouldn't i want to you know
listen to opinions you know i i always
felt like i got where i got by by
listening not by talking
um uh
yeah uh you you've made some excellent
films uh clearly i think you know what
you're doing you might have some talent
behind the camera oh thank you
possibly um so ben is incredible in this
movie and he is giving his heart and
soul and the thing that really blew me
away was when he is singing and crying
at the same time
and that cannot be easy as an actor to
be delivering that those kind of
emotions so can you talk a little bit
about scheduling how you wanted to film
those kinds of emotional moments with
ben knowing you probably can only do it
so many takes you know before there's
nothing left
well the one thing i knew this was an
early conversation that i had with ben
where let's say there was a scene that
required two days of shooting let's say
like uh uh for forever was one words
fail was another like
so what i did was i would ask all right
do you want to sing first or act first
like do you do you need do you need the
do you need the scene to get to it or do
you just want to kind of get it because
i you know get it not out of the way
because he wanted but like what's going
to help you calibrate emotionally what
you what you intend to do and whatever
it is he said that's how i designed the
shooting because uh and that went for
all the actors it's like if i was able
to let's say i i could feel intuitively
that that it you know not ben so much
but like another actor or actress um was
a little bit nervous about the about the
singing well if the others days work
if the nerves would help that kind of
subconsciously then i would i would you
know schedule it at the end of the day
if however i felt like it was
distracting to the person like because
they were so nervous um you know because
singing in front of a whole crew just
staring at you knowing that it said the
crew it's acapella it's terrifying it's
very very very revealing and so i would
use i would use it that way but
ultimately i'm a very pro actor director
i love actors very much like some
most of my friends growing up actors and
i know what they go through and i i know
intuitively what they need and so for me
whatever they need that's what they're
going to get you know um ben especially
because he did as you said he had to go
to these places and just i mean
physiologically speaking i still don't i
saw him do 10 feet away i don't know how
he did it i i it is a remarkable
remarkable just
again just physically i don't know
how you
cry like when i cry and i do
usually i clench my my throat somehow he
cries and it opens up and then he belts
and then he cries again and then it's
it's delicate and it's all authentic and
it's all true it's it's it's an amazing
thing to watch
oh no he's incredible like i mean there
it's
uh yeah i mean i can only say like
there's no other ad you know what i mean
like every adjective you want to use for
his performance it's applicable he just
i couldn't agree more
yeah so wait your phone ring too where
it just did yeah but you know it was a
spam you know what i mean you know
somehow they think you know if i use
your prefix as well you're i don't i
know oh it's unbelievable
uh mine now says spam uh spam call on
the caller
so but yeah i know exactly what you're
talking about what was you obviously
couldn't include all the songs from the
stage and i'm curious what was the song
that made that
came the closest to making the film
before you know but ended up being cut
well you know you you'd be surprised to
hear that
none of them that got caught came close
to being in the movie uh honest to god
it was we felt it like from a very early
it was like the three authors two
producers myself when we sat there um uh
in the off this conference room we just
kept talking over and over about you
know like okay well what is the movie
what's the movie if we include and does
anybody have a map which which i love by
the way i love that song but we're like
well now the movie's starting more more
uh objectively it's not in evan's point
of view
so the singing is different it's more
presentational versus waving which is
the thought in his head
so we all agreed you know it's better to
start with waving because you start with
waving then
then the grammar of what the musical
numbers means is you know it's the noise
in his head okay i know what that means
or um uh to break in a glove which is a
lovely song but knowing instinctively in
that stage of the show or in the movie i
was like you know we just came out of
this incredibly emotional thing with you
will be found and we don't have the
intermission the way they do on broadway
without the intermission
trust me if there was no intermission to
break in a glove i don't think would it
would would even maybe even exist on
stage you need that pallet cleanser and
we didn't have the time because we're
moving forward so that felt like and yet
the scene was so beautiful that stephen
wrote this great version of kind of what
the song was um you know that that
did it uh
that kind of achieved the same
dramatical um the same dramatic uh end
just much more quickly which helps us
get to only us a little faster which
would serve the overall arc of the piece
um in a great way uh in terms of so that
that's to answer your question the other
two songs um it were
one was essentially replaced and others
were replaced you know uh disappear
became anonymous ones so it was kind of
a win-win not only did it eliminate the
the connor as kind of evan's alter ego
which works great on stage but in a real
bedroom would probably would have felt
like a ghost you know so we talked about
that so it became more of a lana's
moment so that was very very that was a
win-win and then good for you
um became a series of scenes but again
just we always looked at the dramatic
structure does the song ultimately serve
the story directly if the answer is yes
it stays if it doesn't and we and it's
achieving the same thing like alana
still confronts him okay so she
confronts him twice now well you don't
need to confront him twice let's let's
move forward and let's just be very
efficient and very lean and because we
knew
also the difference between stage and
film
not to get too granular on it but if
you're if you're interested
kind of what happens is
is the minute you add a close-up to
cynthia murphy
and you feel her grief that much more
intimately
well right away it's different than the
stage show
once you add those close-ups once you
feel the mother's grief once you feel
the stuff of father's grief um
in a different way it just
you know it's just more emotional by
by nature you can't avoid it knowing
that we're like we can't go 2 hours and
40 minutes of this feeling because the
audience will burn out you know there's
like as it is i mean
i think i forget the final running time
you know there were times when i would
watch it as the director and i would
just feel like i can't do it anymore you
know and that's that's with with making
these changes and getting leaner with it
just i was always trying to be
respectful of the audience what they're
going through um and i didn't want to um
i don't know
to me to me there's there's a bond that
you make with the audience where you're
not asking you know you're not being i
guess exploitative i suppose is the
right word we're just like here here i'm
going to present this story the way that
we feel it the way we see it and and you
can make the final determination
as a fan of your work do you know or
have ideas of what you might be
directing next
um there are a few a few irons in the
fire
nothing concrete yet um but everything
i'm involved with i'm really excited
about kind of going back to your
original question of like i think you
know i'm really excited about the next
five ten years you know there's a lot of
things i'm very excited about and
dear evan hansen really brought me
you know because it's the first thing i
i directed that i didn't write
um
and i i loved it i i felt very um
comfortable in this position and so i
think now because i don't have to write
everything um i can make a lot more
films so i'm very excited to move
forward in it yeah i need you making
more movies oh thank you i appreciate it
very much i'm very sincere when i say
that you are a very good filmmaker um
thank you so much for your time i really
appreciate it i appreciate it my friend
all right until the next time
later later